Now, when is Swiss chocolate not Swiss chocolate?
Well, maybe when it's not entirely made in Switzerland.
Toblerone has had to remove the image of the Matterhorn Mountain from its packaging...
...because of strict rules in Switzerland.
It's because it's moving production from Switzerland to Slovakia.
Well, Toblerone say that they will use a more generic mountain image instead.
Well, let's speak to the international branding expert, Alison Stewart Allen.
She's chief executive of International Marketing Partners.
And it's an interesting one, this, isn't it?
Because they've said, look, we're going to move that production.
That's a business decision.
But those strict rules mean it can't call it Swiss chocolate.
That's correct.
And from a branding perspective, this is a bit of a problem,...
...you could say, for Mondelez...
...who have relied on this incredibly successful chocolate around the globe.
This is a brand that everybody knows and everyone associates with Switzerland.
Even the shape of the triangle is meant to mirror the shape of the Matterhorn.
And now, they're going to have to lose the image of the Matterhorn...
...and put a generic mountain of some kind in that iconography.
The challenge though,...
...is that being affiliated with Switzerland brings them great benefit.
And the Swiss brand, if you like, both as a country and the products...
...and services that they create,...
...we all associate these with luxury and with quality.
So, by losing the Swiss affiliation, Mondelez certainly risks us thinking differently,...
...perhaps less highly of this particular brand.